one of the reasons for the drop in  profits was that during the first half  of the year results went against some  racing results for example at ascot  something like  16 out of 30 races were won by the  favorites so that's never very good news  for the bookies that is an industry-wide  problem similarly with some of the  domestic football fixtures again where  where results go to form that's never  good news for the bookies but on a wider  issue we're a few months away from a  general election and you've got  political parties from all sides uh now  talking about heavier regulation on  betting you had harriet harman from  labour for example the other day talking  about  raising levies making bookmakers put  more money back into grassroots sport  and that obviously is going to come out  of the bottom line